Game of Thrones is an epic fantasy packed
with details, and that means some of those
details are bound to leave viewers puzzled
now and then.
Well, you don't need to find a maester to
get your answers, because here's a spoiler-filled
explanation of the most confusing Game of
Thrones moments.
It's never really been clear exactly what
Bran's powers are as the Three-Eyed Raven.
We know he can see events in the past, and
that he can warg into animals - and sometimes
people! - to control them and see current
events.
In the finale, though, he also seems to imply
he can see the future.
"Will you lead the Seven Kingdoms to the best
of your abilities, from this day until your
last day?"
"Why do you think I came all this way?"
This isn't the first time, though.
Back in season 7, he gave Littlefinger's valyrian
dagger to Arya - which she needed to kill
the Night King.
In fact, way back in season three, Bran's
friend and mentor Jojen Reed explained that
greenseers like them can in fact see the future.
"The Raven brings the sight."
"Seeing things that haven't happened yet?"
So how much has Bran known about his future,
and for how long?
It's impossible to say - just like everything
else to do with Bran.
"How will we know the end?"
"You'll know."
Game of Thrones was filled with prophecies,
from Daenerys seeing the show's ending in
a vision to Cersei having the deaths of her
children foretold by a witch.
"Gold will be their crowns.
Gold, their shrouds."
And then there was Melisandre's assertion
that the resurrected hero Azor Ahai would
end the great darkness with his sword Lightbringer.
That one didn't come true.
Or did it?
According to lore, Azor Ahai forged Lightbringer
by stabbing his lover in the heart - just
as Jon did with Daenerys.
Like Melisandre, we all assumed the prophecy
was literal.
But if it was just a metaphor, then maybe
it did happen after all.
The Wall was the shield that guarded the realms
of men.
And then, at the end of season 7, it was destroyed
by the Night King's undead dragon, allowing
the dead to march into Westeros.
And getting a dragon was a lucky break for
the Night King, too, otherwise he might have
been stuck banging his head against that wall
forever.
That's because the Wall was made using ancient
magic that prevented White Walkers from crossing
it.
"The Wall's not just ice and stone.
Ancient spells were carved into its foundations."
"While it stands, the dead cannot pass."
Only the power of a supernatural creature
like the dragon could break those spells and
bring the series to its inevitable conclusion.
At the summit in the dragon pit at King's
Landing, the Lords and Ladies of Westeros
do more than just choose a new king in Bran.
They also create the Six Kingdoms of Westeros,
because Sansa just… nopes out.
"The North will remain an independent kingdom.
As it was for thousands of years."
So why didn't anyone else do that?
Dorne has a long history of semi-autonomy,
but given the massive political upheaval there
with the murders of two consecutive rulers
and their heirs, it makes sense for this random
new guy to make alliances where he can.
Yara and the Iron Islands, on the other hand,
had already negotiated a measure of autonomy
with Queen Daenerys.
"What if everyone starts demanding their independence?"
"She's not demanding, she's asking."
So there's no clear reason why she would agree,
especially given her enmity towards the Starks.
Our guess is that with the Iron Fleet destroyed,
House Greyjoy is simply too weak to risk going
alone - for now, that is.
Seems like Bran is going to have a lot of
work ahead of him to keep this coalition together.
When Jon was sent to join the Night's Watch
at the end of the final episode, even he had
to ask one pressing question:
"There's still a Night's Watch?!"
With the Night King destroyed, the Wall in
ruins, and the Wildlings at peace with the
North, there doesn't seem to be any purpose
to the Night's Watch.
So it's fitting that Jon spends all of five
seconds there before heading even further
north with Tormund and the Wildlings.
What their plans are is unknown, but the way
Tormund seems to defer to him suggests very
strongly that Jon may take his new place among
the Free Folk as King Beyond the Wall.
Not a bad ending after all.
The reunion of Sansa and Arya Stark at Winterfell
was one of the most emotional moments of season
7, but it was quickly replaced by tension
between the sisters.
For the entire season, the two characters
were pitted against each other by Littlefinger.
And then, suddenly, in the last episode Arya
and Sansa were best friends again, working
together to take him down.
Most fans were left to assume that they had
done the obvious thing and just asked Bran,
the living Wikipedia, what was really going
on.
The show never spelled it out, though…or
rather, they just never showed it to us.
In fact, Isaac Hempstead-Wright, who plays
Bran, revealed in an interview that they actually
did film a scene where Sansa asked Bran for
the truth and he uncovered Littlefinger's
treachery.
The scene never aired, but if you were wondering
how and why the sisters suddenly teamed up,
now you know.
After Queen Daenerys is slain, her right hand
man Grey Worm demands justice, leading to
Jon's exile.
And then Grey Worm takes the Unsullied to
Naath.
"We sail for the Isle of Naath."
If you felt like you missed something here,
well…you did.
While the show has never actually shown Naath,
just four episodes earlier, Grey Worm and
his doomed lover Missandei discussed retiring
to the tropical beaches of her homeland.
"Naath.
I'd like to see the beaches again."
"Then I will take you there."
We're not sure how the islanders will react
to being visited by an army of silent eunuchs,
but here's hoping Grey Worm somehow finds
a happy ending - which would be a Game of
Thrones first.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
shows are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.